you know it wasn't a quick hit on
news 11 it was as long as as we had
and so he couldn't escape you know he
couldn't was there's no segment you know
that ended in three minutes and he was
going to take off with the security
detail he was just trapped in the studio
with me
and i wasn't planning on going after him
i'm not i don't really
work that way my
idea when i interview people is i want
to interview people but i will ask him
questions and
he started off so i don't think people
really know
how
intellectually
troubled he is or bankrupt or or
something i don't i don't really know
whether to call him a liar or an
imbecile or just a sell out or whatever
it is
uh suddenly as you were saying that i'm
reminded of a clip you you had gavin
newsom on your show what like a decade
ago or something
yeah a little less but yeah
you had gavin newsom outside so maybe
eight years ago something like that and
uh you you smacked him around pretty
good which i have to tell you as a guy
that fled the state because of that guy
made me feel pretty good
do you hold that one does that have a
special place in your heart
yeah it is um if people can see it on
youtube if they if they like i imagine i
think it's out there
um he came in here i didn't really have
anything against him per se at the time
he agreed to come in and sit down and
did kind of a long form interview with
him
there's a couple of
caveats a
he came in he would never
come in to a place like this now or
anything near anything like that number
one number two
you know it wasn't a quick hit on
news 11 it was as long as as we had
and so he couldn't escape you know he
couldn't was there's no segment you know
that ended in three minutes and he was
going to take off with his security
detail he was just trapped in the studio
with me
and i wasn't
planning on going after him i'm not i
don't really
work that way my idea when i interview
people is i want to interview people but
i will ask them questions and
he started off so i don't think people
really know
how
intellectually
troubled he is or bankrupt or or
something i don't i don't really know
whether to call him a liar or an
imbecile or just a sellout or whatever
it is but
i don't i prefer
frankly i just believe he has no human
soul that's just me there's something
there's something wrong with him and
when i what i mean is is like
kamala harris there's something wrong
with her and that when lester hold us
asking if you've been to the border she
doesn't know what he's saying like that
there's a synapse problem there's
something wrong now look
you can just lie and just go yeah i
haven't been to the border yet but i'm
closely monitoring the border and i'm
planning on going later this week just
just lie but to go i don't know what
you're asking
means something's wrong with you and
something's wrong with a lot of the
biden has something wrong with him
obviously kamala harris uh newsom has
something wrong with him and so there's
a couple of things one is is
i said to him look uh
traffic is is horrible in this town can
we work on traffic a little bit
and he said uh yeah first off it's all
kind of news to him he's like well what
do you want you know what do you want me
to do it's this weird thing you know
where they don't
no you you don't sit in traffic like
you're kind of unaware and i said so i
said a few things i said
in idaho
there's signs by the side of the highway
that says if it steers it clears and in
la
i see people in the third lane on the
405 freeway
both people out of their car because
they had a little bumper bender the cars
are fine no airbags deployed and they're
like standing in the third lane
exchanging information and my thing is
like pull over pull
pull off to the shoulder it's like we
got into a car accident i know the car's
fine just pull it over and get your
information a people get killed that way
it happens
often and b you've stopped the whole
freeway because you guys are having a
conversation
in the middle of the freeway and your
car's run
i said put it up on the freeway sign
just if it steers it clears they they
have them in all the different states
and so the first thing he went was he
went
uh
really
you know
i'll get out of here you know kind of
thing and i said no that's they have it
he's like i never
never heard of that so he never heard of
that and then he rebutted it with this
and this is what
makes gav this is why something is wrong
with gavin newsom he said you know i'd
say i saw something he started chuckling
he goes i saw something i liked i saw a
sign i liked
it said
you're not in traffic
you are traffic
and i kind of like that and i'm like
i don't know what that means
but it certainly doesn't feel like a way
to alleviate the problem
of traffic
so it's an insane statement to say
you're not you know it's like i i'm a
i'm an oncologist you don't have cancer
you are cancer all right my work is done
like i i don't know what he's talking
about then he said
i heard him in another interview
when he went on to a friendly show
but the the person the woman who was
interviewing him at least was had enough
dignity to say
hey people are fleeing california you
know this this was a recent interview
what uh what are we going to do about
that i mean you have thoughts about
people just leaving california
and he said
you know
my answer to that is
where else you're going to go
and the host can think of at least one
place
yeah the host said uh i don't know
florida texas nashville like
just anywhere and then he said yeah i
know i look no i didn't say that jerry
brown used to say that
so he quoted a guy
and then disavowed himself of whatever
the quote was jerry brown
jerry brown in 1974 would say where else
you're going to go and so gavin newsom
decided to repeat that and when the
person said yeah that but that doesn't
make sense he went yeah i know jerry
brown said that that
which means you're you may mean
it means you're insane it means you have
a problem it means you're not thinking
correctly and then he started up
with me i
i said the homeless this is nine years
ago i said the homeless problem
is crazy people and junkies and both
that's who's homeless and then he said
let me explain to you the real face of
homelessness
he prefaced it by saying that was his
main issue and that's what he cared
about the most and then he explained to
me
the real face of homelessness
the real picture of homelessness was a
mother three
whose husband left and who had a minimum
wage job and was forced out into the
streets
and i said that's not that's not who's
living on the streets so very announced
his number one issue
was homelessness he said he was
passionate about it then went on to
explain a scenario that doesn't exist
and now
that was nine years ago and homelessness
is
tenfold worse so that's who
gavin newsom is and i i don't know i
really i'm not i'm always curious why
the people around him go don't don't say
that or like why
that's not the problem of homelessness
is not mothers of three
who are making minimum wage
what do you make of the people that are
bamboozled by him and by the way the
only reason i'm even asking you about
him besides the fact that for some
reason you're still there and i've fled
is that i'm pretty sure that uh as you
know because i'm off the grid at the
moment i could come back and he could be
vice president because i think this
whole thing is completely out of control
they're keeping biden alive on god knows
what and you know he visited the white
house when uh
you know when joe went off to israel
vice president interesting
you know you figure out something to get
nancy out of the way something like that
you get kamala
and um gavin newsom in the same room and
you're gonna have a nothing circle talk
of in complete and utter insanity we're
gonna have two people who make no sense
and who don't track at all
um what i make of it is
la california especially and then
people in general they're very
sort of in hollywood you go now why
you know why hollywood they loved obama
they they they love new some you know
like like why
they're aesthetically oriented and i
don't mean it's all about like matinee
idol good looks they just kind of go
they if they said look i'm gonna show
you a picture i'm gonna take everyone
hollywood and show you a picture show
you a picture of gavin newsom i'm gonna
show you a picture of donald trump who
do you want as a pilot in your airplane
they'll go oh i want that guy with the
jawline for sure he's a much better
pilot he's got to be look at this guy
this guy's this guy's eating a
cheeseburger look at this guy that guy's
my pilot that's it's literally like
they're casting a movie all the time
like you know george clooney looks like
he knows what he's doing you know and
they're so aesthetically oriented and
sort of
paper-thin
and there's such this weird living life
on kind of the veneer surface of life
that they go that guy look at that guy
yeah look at obama that guy and then you
you go well let's talk about policies
saying no no no let's not get
mired in that look at that guy i'd like
to have a beer with that guy
that's basically what they do with gavin
newsom
they're idiots
but that's how that's how it works if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell